Tyrion Lannister has some of the best
lines in Game of Thrones he can be wise
and funny and tragic and cruel sometimes
all at once it's part of why is such a
popular character but Tyrians big mouth
has often gotten him into trouble he's
pissed off a lot of people and one
theory suggests that someday someone
will shot Tyrion up for good by cutting
out his tongue
lots of people in Game of Thrones have
their tongues removed
Ilyn Payne had his tongue cut out for
talking smack about the Mad King and
Marillion in the show loses his for
singing a song in the books Varys makes
his little birds mute taking the tongues
from these children so that they keep
his secrets euron greyjoy cuts out the
tongues of the crew of his ship and
others and some Bolton men lose their
tongues so sometimes it's about
punishment sometimes about keeping
secrets sometimes it's just cruelty and
control for lots of different reasons
lots of tongues come out and some
readers think Tyrion will be next
because Tyrion frequently gets
threatened with having his tongue cut
out
Cersei and Joffrey and Jon Khan and
Jorah and Calaca all threaten his tongue
at some point both bran and Oberyn say
that someone will cut it out one of
these days and Tyrion jokes he should do
it himself because it causes such
trouble so we've got all these direct
hints that someone will cut out tyrians
tongue and there are a few suspects who
seem especially likely Cersei is weirdly
obsessed with cutting out tongues she
mentions the idea in about half of her
12 chapters and Cersei deeply hates
Tyrion she blames him for the death of
Joffrey and is convinced that he'll kill
her because of a prophecy she's
especially always hated the way he makes
fun of her his mockery and criticism
undermines her power and pride
so if Cersei ever has Tyrion at her
mercy in the books it had totally fit
for it a finally silenced her hated
brother
another possibility relates to the
conspiracy of Varys and Illyrio in the
books as this kid called young Griff who
Faris claims is Aegon Targaryen Varys
and Illyrio want to put this Aegon on
the throne but Tyrion seems to suspect
that the boy may not be a real Targaryen
many readers believe this agon is
actually a Blackfyre go watch the Varys
video but the point is that Tyrion may
learn a secret that Varys doesn't want
getting out and since Varys already has
a habit of removing tongues from people
to keep his secrets it's totally
plausible that Varys or Illyrio might
cut out Tyrians tongue to protect their
conspiracy a third possibility is Euron
tyrion hasn't met Euron in the books yet
but Euron is becoming a big bad guy and
he cuts out a lot of tongues so he might
be a suspect as well so it's a strong
possibility that tyrion may lose his
tongue and this could fit really well
with the character arcs of Tyrians
family at the start of the story
tyrians brother Jaime is defined by his
ability to fight with a sword that is
his source of power and pride and
identity until in book three his hand is
cut off and Jaime has to redefine who he
is Who am I now he asks
similarly Tyrion sister so she draws her
power and pride from her beauty and
status which is symbolically stripped
from her in this walk of shame so
there's this pattern of Lannisters
losing what gives them their pride and
power and the equivalent of Jaime's hand
is Tyrion stung Cersei says that Tyrion
wields words as skillfully as Jaime
wields a sword if like Jaime Tyrians
weapon is cut from him he'll also have
to redefine who he is without a tongue
his passions for conversation politics
even food and sex will be affected the
meaning of his life will be at threat
this is a brutal thing to do to a
character but author George Martin does
it over and over not only with Jaime and
Cersei but with bran and aya and Theon
bran loves to climb and ride so George
breaks his back aya relies on her site
to survive so George blinds her Theon
uses sex to feel less insecure so George
gasps treats him when these characters
lose what defines them they're forced to
evolve into a tree God a dark assassin a
hollow ghost it's growth then decay then
transformation and
it makes for great storytelling so
Tyrion losing his tongue would fit not
only all the threats he's received and
the motivations of his enemies and the
pattern in the Lannister family but the
author's overall strategy of breaking
characters down to see what they're made
of and what they can become alt shift X
makes videos using Adobe After Effects
it's taken years to develop this unusual
style of editing and there's always more
to learn and improve for this video we
tried making our motion smoother using
this tutorial on Skillshare Skillshare
is an online learning site with
thousands of classes on design writing
business marketing breathing and video
production there's really high-quality
material here and Skillshare has a nice
community vibe of people learning and
building things together so if you want
to learn a new skill or improve on an
old one whether for work or just for fun
check out skill share at the link below
as our sponsor they're offering a two
month free trial to the first 500 people
to sign up this helps support old shift
X and helps you learn something new
Thanks if you want to read more about
the idea of Tyrion losing his tongue you
might like to read this reddit post by
Homme fast 42 and others thanks to the
patrons including Austin in Gabriel
Maximus Mount Heather Neil on champagne
Walter Pope on to the fourth and
spaceball one sheis